[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a las antenas de
france 24 y radio france internacional
hoy nos acompaña un invitado excepcional
a pocas horas de su despegue hacia la
estación espacial internacional
recibimos al astronauta toma pesqué
buenas tardes
para esta entrevista me acompaña
frederick
efe hola hola silva y buenas tardes a
tomates que toma pesqué cómo se siente
es para horas del despegue en la recta
final
uno se siente impaciente por supuesto
tenemos un poco de margen estos son días
con un poco de margen tenemos muchas
cosas por hacer estamos repasando
nuestras tareas salimos a correr pasamos
de despedirnos de nuestras familias
vamos a pasar un poco de tiempo con
ellas buscaremos los últimos detalles
que corresponden a la logística y eso
nos llevará lentamente hasta el jueves
hasta el momento del despegue es que
tiene la misma confianza en el lanzador
de spacex que en ensayos que utilizó
durante su primer viaje espacial sí creo
que de todas maneras el riesgo en las
misiones espaciales siempre está
calculado por lo general son vehículos
que los lanzadores vuelan por primera
vez entonces hay un riesgo calculado el
riesgo de avería de los componentes pero
nunca se sabe exactamente cómo va a
funcionar porque nunca ha volado en este
caso es un poco diferente tenemos
lanzadores que son reutilizables
entonces es posible pensar que si
funciona una vez no hay razón para que
no funcione la segunda web en todo caso
aunque el lanzador tal con 9 en 10 sólo
desde hace poco tripulaciones hacia la
estación espacial tiene todo un
historial y todo un pasado y lanzando
satélites o misiones sin tripulación y
una fiabilidad digna de la mejores
lanzadores del mundo entonces no no
estamos particularmente preocupados y
por eso el regreso a la tierra será
menos brutal con spacex que con ensayos
no lo sé si le creo a mis colegas que ya
tuvieron la oportunidad de regresar
fueron los dos primeros de la misión de
demostración de todas maneras es
bastante brutal que ellos volaron con la
nave espacial que aterriza como un avión
evidentemente fue mucho más suave pienso
que es un poco similar en realidad los
socios tienen los represores que
amortiguan y se le saltan a 80
centímetros del suelo para darnos
miento final aparte de eso se desciende
casi a la misma velocidad más o menos a
8 metros por segundo aquí imaginarse 8
metros son casi tres pisos o dos pisos y
medio en un segundo incluso con
paracaídas de la cápsula se bajan dos
pisos y medio o tres entonces o bien se
cae el agua en la amortiguación o bien
se cae con un poco de amortiguación
sobre la tía creo que al fin de cuentas
es bastante similar se sacudirá bastante
toma pesqué usted estuvo seis meses en
la estación espacial hace cuatro años
este es su segundo viaje que va a
cambiar durante esta misión alfa muchas
cosas van a cambiar muchas cosas serán
similares lo que será sin duda son los
objetivos globales de las misiones de
seis meses a bordo de acción espacial
internacional son dos cosas la
investigación los experimentos
científicos que no sería posible
realizar en la tierra y poder acceder a
cosas que están ocultas en la tierra
para los científicos por eso nos envían
a realizar los abortos y la segunda es
preparar lo que sigue de la exploración
y eso y todos los días es cada vez más
importante a bordo de la estación y en
la estación es posible repasar las
escalas desarrolló las tecnologías para
poder regresar a la luna ir a marte se
habla mucho al respecto en este momento
es el objetivo de todo el mundo lo que
va a cambiar en la tripulación aunque
tengo la suerte
en dos miembros de la tripulación con la
que ya había volado en cambridge
whisky durante la última misión eso es
muy poco común hay que resaltarlo por
supuesto el medio de acceso a la
estación son dos días o un día de ida y
media jornada de regreso pero son muchas
muchas horas y semanas de entrenamiento
del club dragón el palco el 9 porque es
el momento en el que se corre más riesgo
además el rol a bordo va a cambiar un
poco ahora tengo la experiencia tiene la
oportunidad el honor de ser el
comandante abierto de la estación
espacial si todo sale bien durante la
segunda mitad de mi misión eso quiere
decir que tendré más bien un papel de
liderazgo y le transmitir esa
experiencia que tuve a lo largo de la
primera misión personas para quienes es
su primera misión en el espacio o que
han pasado menos tiempo en el espacio
que yo durante los seis meses que usted
pasará en el espacio se realizarán
alrededor de 200 experimentos
científicos puede contarnos un poco
cuáles son los más importantes y cuáles
podrían tener tal vez una traducción
rápida y concreta a nuestras vidas
cotidianas es happy diputado músico y se
llena
claro por supuesto es muy diverso lo que
hacemos a bordo de la estación esencial
hacemos experimentos sobre la aviación
sobre las espumas porque todas esas son
estructuras que se comportan un hecho
mejor con menos de la verdad entonces es
posible estudiar directamente lo que
ocurre y enviarle los resultados a los
científicos que se ocupan de esos
materiales en la tierra hacemos medicina
porque los virus tampoco se comportan de
la misma manera los cúmulos de células
en tres dimensiones son mucho más
representativos el futuro en el cuerpo
humano lo que es posible realizar en un
laboratorio en una placa de petri como
superficie un poco más plana por decirlo
así hay experimentos a los que les tengo
más cariño creo que en total hay 232 hay
40 de la agencia espacial europea y 12
fueron directamente preparados pero
escenes es decir por el centro nacional
de estudios espaciales francés entre
ellos 12 hay uno que es realmente
emocionantes vamos a estudiar mini
cerebelo son en realidad células madre
que llevaremos a bordo de lejos en
espacial que de nuevo no se comportan de
la misma manera a los científicos les
gusta ver cómo se reproducen como se
aglomera cómo se pueden utilizar en la
tierra y la estación espacial es un
modelo para eso en este caso son células
madre de cerebros entonces llevaremos
los órganos como se les dice
es decir
cerebros que estudiamos a bordo de las
acciones especiales no se parecen a un
cerebro pero se les llama mini cerebros
parece bastante fascinante porque son
inimaginables las aplicaciones que eso
puede tener hay otro experimento que
puede parecer un poco al exótico pero
que no lo es
lo nuevo es con el semen les pedí que
desarrollarán nuevos métodos de empaque
nuevas espumas porque lo que llevamos a
la estación por supuesto debe resistir
al golpe del despegue
este mensaje debe estar protegido de
mercado todo eso genera curaciones
desechos entre comillas abortos de la
estación
no podemos buscarlos con la ventana oa
la basura así que estamos obligados a
almacenar los hasta que haya un vehículo
que vuelva a descender entonces los
desechos son un verdadero problema suena
un poco loco pero les pedí que crearan
empaques que serán comestibles como una
nueva manera de hacer la espuma más o
menos como una especie de pan de
jengibre una técnica estilo
impresionantes de un poco loco pero eso
nos va a ayudar si en efecto eso
dividirá a la mitad del almacenamiento
de desechos y evidentemente tiene la
aplicación directa en la tierra si
podemos reducir los énfasis del plástico
sería realmente formidable y ahora con
una tripulación que tiene bastante
experiencia incluido usted entonces es
posible pensar qué
habrá varias salidas extravehiculares ya
sabe lo que le espera uno siempre se
tiene una idea pero sabe en el ámbito
espacial mientras uno no ha despegado es
difícil bueno es mi actitud mi opinión
es uno no ha despegado es difícil decir
que la moción va a ocurrir yo siempre
tiendo a pensar que ya veremos ese
último momento si todo funciona pues
tanto mejor pero siempre soy un poco no
pesimista pero siempre pienso que pueden
pasar muchas cosas antes de que todo
funcione es parecido con las salidas
extravehiculares por ahora y cuatro
feministas durante nuestra estadía a
bordo por supuesto las vamos a repartir
vamos a utilizar todos los recursos de
la tripulación no sirve de nada que sean
siempre las mismas dos personas dos
claras cuatro salidas mientras que los
demás se quedan adentro todo el mundo
tiene sus talentos todo el mundo es
capaz de hacerlo y está entrenando
entonces no lo sé puede que tengan la
suerte de hacer minutos en todo caso lo
que está en la agenda para esa salida
será mejorar el sistema del equipo de
los paneles solares de la actuación en
este momento los módulos más antiguos de
la estación tienen unos 20 antes
recientes tienen muchos menos pero la
generación de potencia eléctrica está un
poco limitada en relación con el tamaño
de la estación
que accesibles tenemos muchos más
equipos y ahora hay siete miembros de la
tripulación de manera permanente
entonces quisiéramos aumentar un poco el
balance de los paneles solares así que
vamos a instalar nuevos paneles solares
funcionan a explicar si es una
tecnología bastante increíble creo que
pesa más o menos 350 kilos y normalmente
será necesario ir a instalarlos durante
las salidas extravehiculares con esos
paneles solares un poco gigantescos su
mecanismo realmente complicado eso será
una operación mecánica extrema en el
espacio tenemos muchas ganas de empezar
se actualmente está en buen estado la
estación espacial internacional sí está
en muy buen estado la cuidamos en
realidad es como un barco o un submarino
pasamos bastante tiempo fregando la
cubierta mirando las cuerdas lavando las
escotillas en fin por supuesto son
metáforas pero se podrán imaginar que le
prestamos mucha atención a esto queremos
que duren la mayor cantidad de tiempo
posible
aún así los módulos más antiguos como
les dije tienen unos 20 años en un
ambiente tan extremo como el espacio
comparación de la temperatura cada hora
y un ciclo de temperatura más o menos
entre 100 grados unos 100 grados install
o la sombra que todo esté concebido para
eso es un poco difícil los módulos más
antiguos y empiezan a mostrar un poco
los pequeños signos de desgaste externo
nada muy grave de todas maneras sabemos
que la sesión no tendrá problemas hasta
2028 está calculado los ingenieros
asegura que la estructura realmente
estará en buen estado por lo menos hasta
2028 pero creemos que seguirá
funcionando mucho más y cada vez hay más
críticas sobre la estación espacial
internacional sobre el costo de la
estación espacial o incluso sobre su
estado como usted lo mencionó le pone
atención a esas críticas porque es
importante mantener esta estación
espacial no creo que haya cada vez más
críticas lo único que cada vez que se
habla más y más sobre la situación
espacial y eso es algo bueno pero a mí
me parece que al contrario más bien hay
menos críticas ahora que al principio de
mi carrera en 2008 me preguntaban pero
qué vas a ir a ser un espacio para qué
sirve todo esto simplemente porque las
personas no estaban informadas desde
2008 yo realmente he hecho el esfuerzo
de tratar de americanos
y hacemos la exploración y que
consistirá lo que sigue etcétera y desde
entonces me parece que al contrario cada
vez hay más opiniones favorables claro
se habla más sobre la estación por
supuesto aunque haya 50% más de
opiniones favorables sobre el de 25 en
total de todas maneras son más personas
en efecto es importante explicar por qué
hacemos este compresor puestos públicos
con dinero público pero al igual que
cualquier otro instituto la
investigación comenzará en casa
aceleraciones de partículas hay que
explicar para qué sirve siempre es fácil
de entender incluso para nosotros hay
algunos experimentos que hablan esta
mente que no soy físico nuclear no soy
doctor en medicina a veces me cuesta un
poco de trabajo entender pido que me
vuelvan a explicar varias veces para qué
sirve etcétera nosotros debemos hacer
este trabajo de traducir todo esto
cuando es posible porque cuando se trata
de física fundamental no siempre es
posible pero hay que tratar de
traducirlo a cosas de la vida cotidiana
durante esto también toma pesqué como lo
digo usted será el comandante de la
estación espacial durante un mes más
allá de que evidentemente sea
gratificante de que sea
de reconocimiento realmente cambiará
algo para usted vamos a hacer que el
curso
gran guardia todo el mundo no no pondré
en guardia todo el mundo no no lo que
cambia es que efectivamente es
gratificante digamos que es un
reconocimiento sobre todo para un
europeo porque esto no ocurre con tanta
frecuencia somos socios minoritarios en
el programa de la estación espacial no
hay que tener miedo decirlo pero para
nosotros nos sale menos caro que resultó
y nutrientes estadounidenses y rusos
pero claro también tenemos menos poder
de decisión que la nasa
incluso en promedio entre a depuración
tenemos menos roles decisivos' menos
roles de liderazgo entonces es algo muy
bueno es un reconocimiento del papel de
la mesa y mi propio papel en
discapacidad estoy contento lo que va a
cambiar en el día a día con una
tripulación experimentada creo que no
cambiará mucho porque por supuesto no
será un patio de recreo todo el mundo
está ahí para trabajar todo el mundo
está muy serio entonces no es necesario
hacer de policía o decirle a las
personas que organicen su cuarto eso es
seguro lo único que va a cambiar es que
hay ciertas actividades donde trataré de
aportar un poco mi manera de ver las
cosas digamos las actividades de todos
los días
por ejemplo todos estamos de acuerdo en
que hay personas que son más militares y
personas que son más relajadas en tres
astronautas cada uno estables del curso
como quiere y por lo general es el
comandante el que escoge eso además es
sobre todo en situaciones de emergencia
que esperamos no tener pero en ese caso
todo se desarrolla un poco al ritmo del
comandante es él quien escoge los roles
que me asignan las tareas hay más
discusión posible es un liderazgo que se
lleva a cabo durante la acción entonces
ahí no hay intermediarios hay que actuar
como se dijo este es un segundo viaje a
la estación espacial internacional que
le hizo falta que le hace falta de allá
arriba cuando está en la tierra
que hace falta ya arriba creo que tal
vez es evidente lo que voy a decir sobre
las personas cercanas la familia el
contacto humano con las personas que uno
posee en su vida simplemente al mismo
tiempo realmente tenemos mucha suerte
porque podemos llamarlos por teléfono
tenemos teléfonos y que una vez a la
semana hacemos una videollamada a
gestión de skype realmente es mucho
mejor que el principio del programa de
la estación espacial
y cuando estaba a la estación mir es lo
que me hace falta aparte de eso la
libertad la libertad de hacer lo que uno
quiera que tenemos todos los días en la
tierra incluso cuando las personas se
dieran cuenta durante el confinamiento o
más bien confinamiento
desafortunadamente hasta qué punto podía
hacer algo valioso hasta qué punto
podría hacer falta hasta qué punto
habíamos olvidado atrás los amos de ella
tenía los días para nosotros es
parecidos libertad de salir cuando uno
quiera en las actividades que yo quiera
de comer lo que uno quiera de ver lo que
el uno quiera de televisión
desafortunadamente nos quita en todo eso
y durante seis meses pero hay que
sembrar en el otro sentido toma pesqué
porque creo que a eso iba a la pregunta
de silva cuando está en la tierra le
hace falta el espacio
por supuesto si efectivamente funciona
en ambos sentidos el espacio me hace
falta la sensación física de tratar es
extremadamente agradable y no lo voy a
negar con frecuencia las personas tienen
una gran sonrisa porque uno se lidiará
de las limitaciones de su cuerpo flota
fue la realidad pertenece un poco al
ámbito de los sueños de los sueños de la
niñez
agradable por supuesto hay que
acostumbrarse a la vida diaria pero es
agradable personalmente lo que más me
hace falta es este sentimiento de estar
emisión estará en expedición con colegas
la intensidad en el propósito de todos
los días no se levanta por la mañana la
especial sabe por qué está ahí todo el
mundo en el centro de control está para
asegurar que ha trabajo salga bien ese
es realmente un aspecto agradable son
claras uno se dispersa muchos niños como
mérida en la tierra estoy impaciente por
volver a hacerlo
muchas gracias toma pesqué por haber
estado con nosotros en france 24 y ene
efe no se pierdan la cobertura
excepcional que le dedicaremos a este
evento inicialmente con una serie de
reportajes que se empezó a transmitir
esta semana y que se transmitirán hasta
este viernes no se pierdan tampoco la
cobertura del día de con nuestros
corresponsales especiales en cabo
cañaveral en un peluche para france24 en
el sermón ross para rf y tendremos
además esos pequeños vídeos esos
pequeños módulos que usted nos enviará
para hacernos vivir su experiencia allá
arriba durante s
con mucho gusto espero que las personas
me acompañen en esta misión y eso
permitirá sentirme menos sol como sol
gracias tomates que gracias a ustedes
por haber seguido esta entrevista la
información continúen france24 y rf
adiós
[Música]